Et j'ai résolu beaucoup d'enquêtes avec elle..
Dis eh, ça te dit on va dans mon passage secret, on va récupérer des chevaux
et on attaque les allemands !
Eh oh eh !
mais c'est mon livre ça !
Comment ca ?
Bah c'est le livre que j'ai écris
Ouai... Ouai...
Ok, tu te sers de mon livre pour
faire le mécanisme d'ouverture de ta cachette secrète ?
Ouai !
Ok...
Donc t'as arraché des pages enfait...
Oui... mais je les ai gardées.
Ok... Super...
Tu les as gardées où?
Dans une pochette plastique.
Elle est où la pochette plastique ?
Dans ma bibliothèque.
Ah ouai...?
Elle est où la pochette plastique dans ta bibliothèque ?
Elle est où?
Tu l'as rangée où?
Non... elle n'est pas dans cette bibliothèque,
dans ma bliothèque, dans ma maison à...
Biarritz.
N'importe quoi.
Quoi, n'importe quoi?
Si, j'ai une maison à Biarritz,
pourquoi j'aurais pas une maison à Biarritz ?
Euh, je fais du surf, j'adore le surf...,
tu peux demander à Bernardo.
Bah non regarde, il nous écoute pas.
En tout cas, je trouve ça vraiment pas sympa,
ça se fait trop pas ce que t'as fais.
En plus je me rappelle très bien,
c'est un livre que je t'avais dédicacé
j'avais fais un poème personnalisé pour toi
Un truc qui te touche vraiment sur euh...
sur les chevaux.
Ok,
ok, donc on se dit tout ?
On dit qu'on se dit tout ?
Ok, donc quand j'ai fais ce passage secret
je me suis dis...
il faut que je prenne un livre
qui actionne le mécanisme
que personne ne lit, ok ?
Et le livre que personne ne lit...
bah c'est ton livre, voilà.
Je suis désolé, c'est ton livre,
Et en plus tes poèmes, ...
ils riment pas.
Ok...
bah normal, vu que...
vu que c'est de la prose donc...
c'est normal que ça rime pas, donc voilà.
En tout cas très sympa, super sympa
super ambiance
On dit qu'on oublie
et on prend un autre passage secret, d'accord ?
ok, super...
Alors...
Ah d'accord !
Quoi ?
Quoi ?!